[Applaudissements]
la première émission de ben donc pas mon
poste aujourd'hui je prends la place de
civray mena jusqu'à ce que la rue aux
jeunes je m'appelle jeanne et pour ceux
qui se posent la question non je suis
pas une fille cachée de benjamin
castaldi je vous propose qu'on accueille
ensemble les chroniqueurs on commence
par un benjamin castaldi sur sa moto
accompagné de la reine g leygues
bah attention à temps la danse aura
tension va bien attention attention
bonsoir
club
[Musique]
ce qui arrive dans une cadillac de prix
sont durs genton et daniel moment
attention mais je vais réussir on sera
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
dernis accord et sans combat
[Musique]
cali et des géraldine arrivent ensemble
au bo pour rendre hommage à anne et
gauche
peter
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mackay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est des cours de raymond et jean
michel da vais dans un camion qui porte
[Applaudissements]
j'ai souvent dit là
mais les gars
salut
[Applaudissements]
des morts
salut ça m'a
rappelé on y va d'un truc à nous
demander
si
c'est lui karim sobrement wii music
matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
à
e
c'est qui le meilleur
même
si bidji suivi par gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que j'avais demandé à de
leurs mots de me déposer mais
apparemment il n'y avait pas place
et
celui que vous attendez tous suivaient
et les sapeurs pompiers
[Applaudissements]
la servir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
merci
merci merci garder leur verve et bonjour
à tous les chercheurs autour de tp on ne
pouvait pas commencer cette saison sans
rendre hommage aux héros de cet été les
sapeurs pompiers tous les pompiers
[Applaudissements]
merci le shérif venez on est avec david
brenner président de l'union
départementale des sapeurs pompiers de
la gironde n'ont pas travail
exceptionnel merci c'est bon c'est bon
ne traite pas voté chaque année c'est le
kata et jade jade elle est incroyable
majad c'est booba qui m'a fait découvrir
et ma chérie je suis très heureux que tu
sois là c'est extraordinaire ça va chez
les dames 1 merci d'être là pour la
première mais que ce soit toi qui loue
la première est ce que tu veux bien être
avec nous parfois une fois par semaine
oui c'est vrai tu viens réagir surtout
oui je te dis ou pas
faire un petit coucou à dubaï dont nous
regarder c'est lui qui sait quand sa
lutte et la tulipe un petit bisou
merci d'être là machine
pourrait qu'on l'applaudisse traitant
aussi david berger président de l'union
départementale des sapeurs-pompiers de
la cire les pompes et météo de cet été
ont discuté il ya un stand à vis de tout
ce qui s'est passé cet été et
aujourd'hui je voulais absolument
démarrer cette saison par vous parce que
vous n'êtes ni roux vraiment de de cet
été on a énormément penser à vous tous
les français et derrière boucher que
vous avez eue vous êtes tous mobilisés
on pense à couper les victimes a bien
sûr des incendies qui est partout en
france et bravo je vais vous dire bravo
david je sais que vous allez me dire
avec notre métier mais vous avez été
formidables je voulais absolument vous
voir ce soir vous passez fait pas effacé
passer un message aussi aux français qui
nous regardent mais merci série
l'incendié
250000 sapeurs pompiers de france qu'ils
soient professionnels volontaires
militaires qui se sont mobilisés sur ces
feux à la fois en gironde mais partout
sur le territoire national dans les
bouches du rhône dans l'hérault en
bretagne dans le jura et c'est cette
force des secours qui tout au long de
l'été a été aux côtés des français et
des françaises on pense aussi à nos amis
corses ont décidé qu'ils ont et voilà
qu'ils ont vécu des moments très
difficiles et on pense très fort à eux
est vraiment david voilà on vous voulez
vous avoir aujourd'hui parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu cet été ça ça a marqué
l'été de tous les français vous pouvez
pas mal à ne pas penser à toutes les
victimes à vous tous les pompiers qui
avaient fait un travail exceptionnel je
dirais qu'on vous parle et je lui disais
bon il ya eu malheureusement il n'y a
jamais de vacances pour les pompiers
l'été est toujours la période où les
gens prennent du bon temps et où nous
devons être sur nos gardes de façon à ce
que les vacances se passe du mieux
possible que ce soit sur les plages que
ce soit en montagne que ce soit sur le
terrain des feux de forêt on le dit les
soldats les sapeurs-pompiers sont les
soldats du feu les soldats de la vie
tous les jours sur dans les villages et
villes de france et puis aussi les
soldats du climat vous l'avais dit en
corse ce fameux orage qui a créé des
drames et nous sommes là pour être sur
le terrain c'est l'engagement citoyen
des sapeurs pompiers de france alors ce
soir on voulait également vous dire
avec répéter on va aider voilà côté du
team on va faire un gros don voilà dès
ce soir pour vous aussi les pompiers qui
avaient fait un travail exceptionnel
voilà je voulais vous dire en tout cas
david on sera toujours là si vous avez
besoin de faire passer des messages si
vous avez besoin d'être si vous avez
besoin qu'on relève des informations
vous n'hésitez pas vraiment vous ne le
dites et on voulait vraiment démarré
cette saison par vous parce que vous
êtes les héros de cet été j'aurais qu'on
a police très fort
bravo à tous les sapeurs pompiers serait
qu'on applaudit jade également avec jade
merci les chéris merci merci merci merci
et on va rejoindre maintenant le plateau
alors je vous explique il ya tous les
chroniqueurs qui sont là aujourd'hui
enfin il en manque quelques-uns voilà
que vous allez bientôt retrouver au
cours de la semaine et ensuite vous
allez découvrir dans quelques instants
deux nouvelles têtes qui vont intégrer
tpm p alors vous allez voir le plateau
il n'a pas changé de fou 1 déjà pour des
problèmes de budget je vous expliquerai
mais vous allez voir on a tout misé sur
le nouveau look des chroniqueurs vous
allez retrouver dans un instant seul hic
nous avait beaucoup réclamé jean michel
maire qui fait son retour dans
l'émission dès la première vous allez
retrouver également mathieu delormeau et
la plus frais que jamais qu'à passer des
vacances à mykonos incroyable il va nous
en parler dans un instant vous allez
retrouver canivez novelli qu'à une coupe
qui a changé elle a refait la coupe à
l'ancienne voie ou pas quand elle était
djette vous allez voir également bien
sûr géraldine maillet qui est là et qui
nous donnera encore des leçons cette
année c'est pour ça qu'elle est là c'est
pour ça qu'on l'ait mme valérie bénaïm
et là il ya benjamin castaldi qui est là
vous allez voir un look dégueulasse
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il s'est
passé sans déconner on dirait qu'il a
été un concert d'un gars des années 90
un concert de dick rivers vous allez
voir ça à d'autres instances dirigeantes
on est très fatigués parce qu'il a animé
la matinale bas ce matin et puis il y
aura bien sûr daniel mots et vous allez
voir daniel bourgault scoop je crois
qu'elle est sur un gros dossier on y va
c'est parti le plateau est là à venir
[Applaudissements]
les résultats donnés par
mr
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien
mais savez vous nous avez manqué c'est
pour ça que chaque année je démarre
assez tour 18h10 ça coûte très très cher
assez vite
parce que je sur facture cette
demi-heure jeu là sur facture mais je
suis tellement heureux d'être là merci
au public est aussi longue
[Applaudissements]
c'est la douzième rentrée de tpm paix et
j'ai appris grâce à un journaliste je ne
savais même pas que j'étais leur korman
pour une émission en direct pour un
animateur jamais un animateur ni rester
dont saison
et comme on a signé quatre ans je vive
les jeudis les seize saisons les chaises
saison après bien entendu on fera les
vins
on comptera les chroniqueurs décédé
ensemble chaque semaine mais daniel
j'espère que vous
et d'ailleurs quand je pense à des
chroniqueurs décédé j'ai toujours une
petite pensée pour nicolas pernikoff
qui nous regardent de là haut nico qui
ressuscitera certainement cette semaine
il va revenir sachez qu'il a fait un
très bon pilote mais chéri j'ai pas de
chose à boire
voilà il ya toujours une petite console
ne croyez pas sur les autres chaînes
tarifs sur france 2 sur tf1 ça va nous
nous on vit et on fait selon mitti la
peur over
vous le sachiez quand j'arrive sur le
plateau de ses huit je sais pas ce qui
va me tomber sur la gueule là ils vous
ont fait une ambiance cathédrale du son
du ka on va faire une ambiance disco tu
vois je vais pas ce qu'ils foutent henry
son plaisir en plus il faut savoir que
sur la première en fait il ya des gens
il ya plein de gens qui viennent nous
voir en régie tout ça on sait pas qui
sait ils sont contents d'être là pour
dire on était sur la première donc tout
le monde n'est pas concentré en régie
ouais non je veux dire personne est
construit donc je vous le dis il y aura
bien sûr n'est pas technique c'est
normal cc 8 on change pas une équipe qui
gagne d'accord vous le connaissez bien
sûr chez vite vous connaissez un petit
peu la règle toute la journée barnaby
devant barda
[Musique]
on continue à dormir avec apple c'est
sincère
on ouvre un oeil à la pub du 6 à 7
et on se réveille quand j'arrive ensuite
on se rendort
devant les films de ses huit on a acquis
je vous dis pas mal de séries qui
cartonnent est sûre ça soit dans mon jeu
lille mercredi soir et énormément de
gens se sont endormis devant la semaine
dernière
merci à eux non j'adore cette
double de
cire et vous m'avez énormément manqué
sachez le ah non mais moi en plus moi
j'ai passé un été les gars sont écornés
j'ai passé plus de temps en vacances
l'année dernière que dans l'émission les
vacances j'ai cru que j'allais chaabi
revenir non mais sans déconner jamais
représenté saillie quoi c'était fini
quoi j'étais un joueur de pannon
je n'y a pas une personne c'est éthique
qui m'a parlé les gars me parler tout de
baden non mais ça y est c'est un truc de
fou alors là donc je me suis bien au
chaud c'est beau ça va les gars et puis
on va prêter des relations à une
relation notamment on a dit que
finalement après tout toutes les
relations qu'on m'avait prêté finalement
j'étais avec diego
légaux regarder des baux voilà voilà
diego qui est là voilà paraît que ça
fait cinq ans qu'on est ensemble voilà
voilà voilà bon je vous le dis je suis
pas prêt encore
je suis pas prêt voilà on va en parler
dans un historique matthew qui
m'attendent à mykonos
pour l'instant pour l'instant je ne me
sens pas ça peut évoluer tout pète tout
peut évoluer dans la vie regardez
benjamin castaldi avant il avait pas de
ça maintenant il est meilleur mais c'est
vrai
mais c'est comme un scoop c'est la
première fois que vous dites que votre
sexualité peut évoluer
joli je pense qu'on fera d'abord les
quatre saisons qui
voit là on va pas aller trop vite en
besogne merci je parlais de vos looks de
voter dans un instant lorsque je vois
des choses déjà quoi ça va pas y prendre
à venice n'hésite pas à ta merde patrick
c'était pour moi ça alors c'est vrai oui
je suis désolé si elle même c'est pour
moi oui je peux vous sucer pour faire
pardonner
attention oui mais tu m'enlèves des
villages
[Rires]
jean bélony vous m'avez manqué comme
jamais non mais franchement il faisait
un truc de fou deux mois et demi de
vacances non mais c'est dur quand vous
dites vous m'avez manqué c'est à dire
les creuseurs ou le canot mail alors la
casse chez le roi pour l'instant vous
n'existez pas
là je parle du publié à l'automne et des
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent en
direct parce qu'on est en direct
montraient encore en direct cette année
et les chéris je vous racontais un petit
peu ce qui va se passer cette année
d'abord arabes ont toutes choses cette
année déjà jours à compter dé à ce qui
va se passer aujourd'hui
déjà dans un instant on parlera de cette
affaire moi j'étais tranquillement quand
tu joues au paddle tranquille j'étais en
train de kif et je mangeais des
croque-monsieur sans khallouf
[Rires]
l'état sont à chaque fois moi chaque
fois que l'on voit un truc aussi oublié
d en mettre toujours leur alloue le mec
en ont marre tu vois je vous des
croque-monsieur sans rallonge des pâtes
bolognaise sens venant non mais tous ou
tu vois je vois jouer mais tout ça est
donc j'étais tranquille et là je vois
deux sortes unither la toile s'agite
hanouna est mêlé dans la sphère d
influence voleurs
bien entendu je vais en parler dans un
instant on aura l'avocat de booba qui
sera avec nous dans un instant et je ne
sais pas pourquoi je sens que booba
passera peut-être une texte
ne s'est pas
tu as romans paris on va parler
également de vous vous et votre avenir
[Applaudissements]
on va parler également de cette affaire
mathias pogba boli on est en attente
d'une vidéo exclusive aura toutes les
infos de mathias on est en attente ça
peut arriver à tout moment où ça
n'arrive pas mais je vous le dis mathias
que je connais bien qui était venu en
plus pour son association et je vous
raconterai que la sphère d'accord on va
voir également un philippe carayon qui
viendra nous voir de canal+ qui nous
racontera tout ce qui se passe autour de
cette affaire vraiment tout le monde
m'en parle
midi j'étais au restaurant cet après
midi je suis allé prendre un goûter
ce matin le petit déjeuner
tout le monde ne me pas que de ça et
bien bien sûr vous le savez ce sera dans
tpm paix que vous aurez toutes les infos
et peut-être une excuse je vous tiens au
courant pendant l'émission puisque nous
sommes en direct